france and germany are promising to
spend more than 500 million euros to
support vaccine production in africa
the european union also plans to deliver
more than 100 million doses of vaccines
to the continent
this year many african nations are
struggling to secure vaccines on the
global market
and south africa is entering a third
wave of infections
our correspondent adrian kriesch reports
from durban
less than two percent of south africans
have received a jab so far
not even 1 million people many south
africans are not happy about the slow
roll out of the vaccination program
but the government says they simply
cannot get their supplies earlier
because of
the massive global demand and also
because many industrialized countries
secured themselves huge quantities of
vaccines
south africa has ordered vaccines for 75
of its population but only a fraction of
that has arrived in the country
this is why french president emmanuel
macron and german health minister jens
spann are visiting south africa
to support technology transfer and the
establishment of regional manufacturing
centers
france committed up to 500 million euros
germany will invest up to 50 million
we are very keen to support and
cooperate in this area with other
countries
around the world we think it is very
important
that we can make it possible that
everyone on the world
that wants to be vaccinated can get
vaccinated we
are only safe when everyone is safe
south africa has been a leading voice
speaking out against lack of vaccine
access for poor countries and demanding
an intellectual property waiver for
covet-19 vaccines
and on this we are not going to retreat
because for us to retreat means that
we are saying our people's lives are not
worth much the lives of our people
are worth a great deal and we do this
because we want to save our people's
lives
and we're therefore going to continue
insisting that this waiver should be
there
so far not a single vaccine is produced
in south africa from scratch
only one covet 19 vaccine is partly
manufactured here
filled in vials and distributed experts
say it will take a long time to create
the necessary capacity
time that south africa doesn't have
infection rates have been increasing in
the past days
the country is going into a third wave
and people who are under the age of 60
are still not sure
when they will be able to get inoculated
again dw's adrian kriesch filed that
report from south africa he caught up
with the german health minister
yen span there to find out how germany
plans to help
france and germany pledged multi-million
euro support for south africa to create
local vaccine production capacity can
that still make an
impact and a difference in the short run
to fight this current pandemic
yes it can and it must make a difference
because you see a 99 of the vaccines
used here in africa are coming from
outside from abroad
are imported to africa and we want to
support
for now for this pandemic situation but
as well on mid and long term we want to
support south africa and africa as a
whole to develop its own
pharmaceutical industry in this regard
for vaccination
production manufacturing but and that is
actually what i discussed with president
jeremy poser and president macron last
night
during dinner as well for research
because we have so many neglected
diseases we have covet 19 now we need to
focus it but there are so many
neglected infectious diseases especially
here
in africa that need research too and
then
speed up of production but isn't it
rather a long process most experts say
it will take months possibly years until
the capacity can be really set up and
the
know-how and technology transfer can
happen definitely it will take some time
some months
and that is already quick but we have
seen it that quick in this pandemic
situation already with test transfer and
that is why we
actually count on voluntary partnership
between patent holders companies like
biontech
kurovec from germany others that
are actually willing i know from them
they want to cooperate and we
actually count on cooperation because
that makes it easier if there's
voluntary cooperation
then the tech transfer the cooperation
between the
experts the staff is much much easier
and we do have companies here in south
africa like aspen or biowag
that actually do already meet the
world standards aspen is producing
already for the world market for example
for johnson johnson
and that shows it's possible needs some
time some months
but that still could make a big big
difference for this pandemic
south africa's president once again
during a visit ask for an intellectual
property waiver
he says this will make things faster
this will make the availability of
vaccines in africa
faster even the french president macron
also said mr president
we are behind you on this idea why is
germany against it if you
look at the goal what are we aiming for
that is
speeding up and actually making it
possible in general that there is a
manufacturing here in south africa and
africa
and really to to speed it up to really
make a difference and not just a
general debate cooperation is the way
because you know this is about a very
complex product
product the production of vaccines is
one of the most complex
things in the world and for that you
really
need to know how you do it just the
patent alone
does not make the vaccine and for that
the cooperation is really essential
it's crucial and i see that most of the
companies that have developed
a vaccine against kobe 19 are really
willing
to cooperate with companies for example
here in south africa
and what we want to do with money with
financial resources but
as well politically is to support this
and to to push them even to be faster
minister thank you very much thank you
you